[Music]
hey good humans before we start this
episode we've got a big announcement to
make we're going to be having a are you
tired of seeing this guy intro every
single jubilee video
what about sick christians versus one
atheist oh i like that or how about
republicans and democrats perfect are
you tired of seeing the same episode
ideas over and over again do you have a
better idea for an episode that you're
dying to see
meeting in five minutes
are you tired of always working do you
need a vacation well jubilee is doing a
sweepstakes where you can win the chance
to appear in an intro on set for one of
our videos one lucky winner will get one
minute of fade but that's not all you'll
also get your ideas heard because you'll
win a chance to help us decide on a
topic for one of your favorite jubilee
series but it doesn't stop there we'll
fly you down to la pay for your save for
the weekend and to top it off we'll give
you tickets to disneyland
you can enter the sleep stakes by buying
any item of merch from our store
starting now through friday august 27th
at 11 59 pacific time one lucky customer
will be chosen at random and contacted
via email please see the link in the
description for complete and official
rules must be 18 or older and a u.s
resident not eligible for rhode island
residents no purchase necessary woodwork
prohibited
[Music]
i teach little kids how to code and i
have to deal with them all the time
photographer now but i used to work at
apple retail give me a number
a trampoline
[Music]
we brought together seven extroverts i'm
an extrovert i am an extrovert i'm an
extrovert i'm an extrovert i'm an
extrovert i'm an extrovert i am an
extrovert
one is an introvert if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who
is the odd one out
so okay not everybody talk at once yeah
first
thought that comes to your head when you
think about what an extrovert is
outgoing and friendly outgoing
and enjoys uh meeting new people
yeah because we like get energy from
being with people yeah
not the same as talkative there are some
introverts who talk yes
that kind of was like overcompensating a
little bit maybe i don't know it was
just a lot of energy i think it's valid
to realize that you need to have a
balance though as an example yeah yeah i
think what a lot of people don't know
you should also just take a step back
sometimes i'm in a bad mood and like it
doesn't mean that i'm an introvert it
just means that i'm a human being yeah
it all fluctuates or like do you ever
like just like kind of you can just um
reflect energy from other people yeah
like it's easier
to just reflect energy yeah brian i
thought he was either introverted or on
a blurry line of extrovert to introvert
he seemed like he was acting a little
bit an extrovert who has good people
skills and can lead a group isn't always
talking the most that's yeah yeah yeah
i've been in a lot of like small groups
for like 20 size people and i love those
sizes because you get to meet a lot of
people but you're not always talking
already
[Music]
it was just an eeny meeny miny moe
choice between allah and zed and i was
like allah didn't talk
she was the quietest in the group i
thought maybe she was just kind of like
cutesy and quiet
we counted all the votes and we have a
tie the tie is between zed and brian
each of you is going to get 30 seconds
to state your case
funny um
i just got a little nervous in the
beginning but i like to heal people out
first and then i start like getting
energy
but i felt a lot of energy from ellie a
lot and we did talk over each other a
lot
so i mean
okay
but uh yeah um i'm very outgoing very
fun all right y'all i am super
extroverted literally 100
i mean entj on myers briggs and i love
talking to people all the time literally
planning on getting all your phone
numbers after the show because we should
hang out usually the show votes off the
most like stereotypical person first so
i was trying to not be like super
lovely but i like love people
i have to do it
zed could have been overcompensating but
he did seem very assertive in how he
felt about
i'm so himself
it's okay i'm sorry
it's fine
girl
like honestly that's the
i was just at a low energy spot i was
feeling it out and so i was like okay
whatever so i wanted to talk about the
elimination and let me let me say my
thing and then i want all of us to do
that too if that's okay yeah i don't
think he was the mall i thought you were
the mall and i voted for zed because
i felt like he was just overcompensating
i definitely wasn't over compensating if
anything i was under compensating but
you were the one out of the group that
was really over excited and i was just
like he did stand up yeah
for sure i honestly would have tried you
not
i'm sorry it was so confusing it's okay
i could not hear anybody talking there
were like two people that stood out
but you're just like so cute and sweet
and like oh you're so cute
who did you vote for you i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry
no no no it's okay
i didn't know anyone so i just had to
choose someone i was so excited
if you don't know it's because you're an
introvert and you know that you're the
mole i wasn't sure because he gave a
very convincing answer
but then you went up to speak and dude
i'm gonna be honest you just seem like a
genuinely very nice guy if i were
extroverted like yeah i'd want to get
everyone's phone number i'd be like hell
yeah man oh
that's weird because maybe he's slipping
up right now maybe he
is an introvert and so that's why he
said if i were an extrovert we have we
have like six she's like a question i
was thinking yeah yeah so if you wanted
to go first and then you want to go next
yeah i was do you have a specific like
question or question okay because she
took the lead she seemed very assertive
very sure of herself and that felt to me
like she was just doing everything she
could to throw suspicion off of herself
what do you guys do as hobbies okay
i like that can i go first go first all
right just kiss yeah okay so um what do
i do is hobbies
so um let's see i'm an actor so so just
oh oh no way so like so you know like
you got them right there right there i
mean same way you have to be extroverted
um well because i was gonna say i
actually didn't wanna say i was an
actress because i was worried they would
plan to see that they're like oh she's
faking but i'm not just on stage i'm
actually a filmmaker she started talking
about acting because i brought up acting
she seemed to get very defensive and she
avoided eye contact i love going to the
ocean i play the ukulele awesome and
like i'm in sales so
like that just gives you a lot for what
i do as a job i actually work at build a
bear you have to be like an extrovert
and someone who's good with people to
work there and it's like oh it's so
life-giving i love it i actually have
all mine in seas christ coffee cycling
computers cameras and chests
alliteration
so i work at a trampoline park right now
you can't work there if you can't handle
kids teens adults but my hobbies i love
being outdoors i'm a dizzy fanatic so
when i go to disneyland and i see
birthday pins i literally go up to
random people and i say happy birthday
okay
these people are
most likely extroverts but at the same
time are their occupations and their
hobbies like really giving us the
information we need
something really quick yeah because
everyone's talking about job and in the
same time
i teach little kids how to code and i
have to deal with them all the time i do
filmmaking but i also i'm also a
mediator he helps kids code
a photographer now but i used to work at
apple retail for three years give me a
number
big air a trampoline park
yeah yeah
[Music]
mostly because she seemed a little
low-key low energy and it seemed like
she was trying to push her energy
she like admitted that she didn't know
who to vote for and like she was just
really good at acting like bubbly
[Music]
so we counted all the votes and we have
a tie oh my god
another one
the tie is between aaliyah and ellie
you guys are gonna get 30 seconds each
to tell us your most extroverted
experience so first of all when i was
taking the myers-briggs personality test
i scored a 99 in the extroverted
category second of all the big like
extrovert experience was two weeks
straight in guatemala with a big group
of people we like did things non-stop it
was so fun also
i have plans right after this and i'm
going to hang out with people
immediately after that
so i told you guys about job
so we don't get to ever see each other
in person even the people that live
close by like we just like don't hang
out too often one of our co-workers who
lives in oregon he actually came in for
two weeks and he was in town and i
literally brought everyone together like
i was one to bring her into my house and
then on top of that like i'm just laid
back guys but i'm like for sure
extroverted that's all i gotta say
[Music]
it's definitely her
wow
i am such an extrovert but good luck
besties i didn't vote for you this time
oh so sad i really wanted to be able to
win this i wasn't like the biggest
personality but also i was able to talk
so maybe they just voted me because i
was just kind of in the middle please
raise your hand if you still have doubt
and want to continue playing the game
because i want to ask a question
specifically to you okay yeah because
right now straight up my doubts i'm
gonna trust my gut it's still yours i
still have that's about you and i have
doubts about you just because
i don't know what but
you when you said your occupation like
okay filmmaker you you write plays and
stuff but when you look at like famous
people right now they can be extremely
extroverted when they're on the stage
and then you leave and like you'll watch
like behind the scenes and they're like
sitting in the corner on their phone i
wanted to ask you
what's something that's like extremely
extroverted that you do at work you
don't understand this okay when you're a
director you are literally in charge of
everything you're holding the strings on
every single person you need to make
sure everyone's doing what they're
supposed to be doing you need to make
sure everyone's safe
it's crazy and insane and a lot of
people i think they think because you're
behind the camera it means that you
don't want to be seen you don't want to
be in the spotlight but i really thrive
in that kind of environment while she
was talking she was trying to gain her
energy back she was talking about what
she does for others in the environment
but not very much what she felt that's
what about you what's something really
extroverted that you do i was at a party
right okay and i got
super drunk and i woke up and had so
many people's instagrams followed on my
phone oh okay i don't know how this
happened but this somehow did and like i
i think that just goes to show like i
love talking to people in 2015 i went to
like a church potluck a sunday afternoon
everyone wore name tags because that's
what you did at potlucks accidentally
went to a grocery store afterwards with
the nametag still on
two different people made the same joke
it's like oh hey zed how's it going and
so i realized that's two people i met
that i wouldn't have otherwise met i
literally wore a hello my name is
sticker for an entire year after that no
way so that i could have more
conversations with you that is so that
is
very sweet
that is a very extroverted thing yeah
you're you're not you're not an
introvert i'm a big reader i've read my
whole life so if you brought up like
football or like you brought up
filmmaking i've read something about
that because i hate not being in the
know
so that that's that's why i know a lot
about introverts right guys honestly
i don't think the mole's here
i know or something
i just
but like you also have been taking lead
and you've been doing a really good job
like if you are lying yeah wow
i don't know why because you're the one
that's like taking control and i feel
like if i was an introvert that's what
i'm saying exactly
i don't want to say that it's you but
okay i felt
sad because i thought they betrayed me
honestly that's how i felt okay seven
six
i voted for her because she seemed like
she was voting for me
even though i loved that all i was
taking initiative maybe she's just it's
all for show
[Music]
we have a tie yeah the high is between
allah and alia oh we're gonna now go
into another round of votes
i saw that coming
i honestly didn't dude
yeah
this game you're back i
dang like
you're wrong like
please raise your hand if you want to
continue
majority has voted and we will end the
game
now
hopefully you guys voted out the correct
people and you guys win wow if the light
turns green that means you have voted
out demo and you win if the light turns
red that means the mole is still in the
box and you lose
oh
is it you or is it alex
why didn't you all raise your hands is
it yours i really thought it wasn't
yours or alex
i had a feeling something felt off i am
mad not only that i lost i was the only
one who raised my hand
will the introvert
please step forward and reveal yourself
in three
two
one
i knew it
very
upset i'm not gonna lie because i knew i
was right i felt so bad
because we were making friends but i
felt really good that i won
when i was a little girl i was an
extrovert i hated being by myself and
around 14
i noticed that i no longer enjoyed being
in groups anymore for me being an
extrovert means loving getting to meet
new people and hearing their stories
sharing my own story is also very fun
but it's not a one-way street so in the
same way that introversion does not
correlate all the time with social
anxiety or being shy um extroversion
does not mean that we never get nervous
as an extrovert i'm sending love to all
the introverts take your money
no lunch is on me you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is gonna buy so many books i
swear to god